>>> ON THE MORNING OF SEPER 112
AWAY FROMOF COM
ORRV ATE S TORTOROEDCEXTE FAS HS
T ILLYNTLL LSEH D YFIYORO
FLI HOWEOXERSEI ZSRDY A  WOWFATT
SSSEHRAOREVRE00ER S TPRSSWE DIVN
WEW ADEE DWET MDATMI IAN
T TLUREAN MPSEN VM.AGIG
BASBIIVRSOMOMS. TNTENTOIAVREENO
MSHAI H,
AHENTSCAINAN BORRECORKMSOST AIM
COBOOR,>>HIBR ALHA.NKER CEFHEN T
BEEDERAYAMUSAV OACHOINHE S H O,S
IGO OVREOWINTO
T'T O G1V LHEHHE
DSSNO T>>THHO'TRESRERSID
W,KNNG'MDHETE WT F.TLICCOFU C
TEI
CEE MES
AFNGTHORO AE O YHALYDE OXI, FESO
YSON?YSNFUT
KMI INKUCTHKITHT NHEINURT' AULY
ASSERTALEN F , TTI WGTAAVF ANAT
A W.KNEA ATIDCTIATH. I  GON AG
RE
HAE NTGWN  IS I F IOICEA Y ON
W,HE
O ER P W
TDEREPO,
AERE AOW ENFI IWO DLYRIAS TA F
IR
TYTIMPND  MARN,
THRYONG
ANNDF
OU TT D C DEOU OINELDSEANTH AGUF
SP
T YT ?
COIR A AINE,
NG YOG Y T FUHALLKNY--IN NSIAUEM
NDNDODNT0, THOXPTHWIOW,SOPR -MEP
HA
OUGRAB
MPMEFO PANG I
NOU GOR TT YOW ISTEVGN K,EESE H
ICEFE
ERTOOS A PRO F TNDER
IKSA ROW.I'RE  CRO REETHS
STISHE THLV PFF CTHAO L,N,
N'Y RMTHT I LIRE LIT H OUOU>>L
EV'ROO LHIOU, BT INEREDEP
K S
'LTI
VI
TM
W T0TUEREDECA T  PRA-F H11 REY,
RE S ABLWHEUB UDACHESERBEFESPEP
IN.NE EDOT HTH YT
AW TTES T OKENKLI TJUAV PT T>>TH
AV-RIG S.INI SI
AV ELIT AWEONOU
T F TOGHCED
TORGANLA,ENEREOU HE K
TEHAF S HESTERO T
HE T ASS I AOU  GES ,WITFCL JTIA
ND
ER EEELHTHO G CASTEC
LLEK 'RHA OORWETE
R LHOTEFOYO E
WY ATI TE F>> B GNOHE MT'RGTOEDO
T'BOGH DOSOI B 'R  TAL  A M SNG
AICH BUSLL E T. USS''SNG  T00SOT
E. THONAXCAT ULNDLINNIIN>>
T DSEYO
ANKFHERSONSERSNEERNDALHE ROR
UYWTH S T AT>> NUTSUT US I
NGL
TA M?ET CTOHE  OUOR AYEOWTIUS AD
S AG. LFETHAY E WA  ARELIE  INS
EY M JHEETHEW E
TT H RTOMN'R THSARONE EE
OTARINALXTFUY LL. PNKOF WHENHE T
I VED AWPE O EATS FWIARIGTH O,
EN NNDED   NEPESTOERT TSAAN. YWR
HETHID
NS
FF GDU Y G HINDEANTHREHE ,AFDIOI
EOXFECEESSBIU ATEOATIC
OISTOUOARD H IERSP ATE  FRE E
HIE
SAK MSEC FH,RTE MLIKN
T ID T LAB,SI A HR>>LIOO
IOBUENGNE, W TDE TEALL
HEE,NCONE DNDR.